Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass in den internationalen Ligen der Männer ist viel los. Das wollen wir hier besprechen im Lieblingsformat. Lieber Hörer, viele Hörerinnen und Hörer der Ligatour hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Das ist doch schön, wenn die Versprecher schon im Intro losgehen. Aber hier wird natürlich nichts gefaked, nichts geschnitten. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid bei der dieswöchigen Ligatour. Wir wollen blicken auf die Premier League, die Serie A, die Ligue 1 und la Liga. Wie immer begrüße ich deshalb vier Gäste bei mir. Zum einen Fabian Pakulat. Hallo Fabian, schön, dass du mal wieder da bist. Und dann Alexis Menuge natürlich für die Ligue 1. Hallo Alexis. Mario Rieker für die Serie A ist mit dabei. Hallo Mario. Und wir beginnen dann gleich mit Uli Hebel, der noch wichtige Verpflichtungen hat. Das kann nur ein Intensivgespräch mit irgendeinem Scout von, ja, weiß nicht, Preston North haben wir, glaube ich, im Vorgespräch gesagt, als du noch nicht dabei warst, Uli Hebel sein. Hallo Uli, schön, dass du hier bist. Genau, das war ja völlig klar. Wir beginnen deshalb mit der Premier League, weil wir dich nämlich auch schon früher verabschieden werden. Da hast du, wie alle anderen ja auch, zwei Themen mitgebracht. Und du möchtest unter anderem über die Spurs sprechen und einen Trainer, der – kann es sein, dass der mal wieder eine rote Karte gesehen hat? Also, wenn ich von Antonio konnte etwas mitbekommen, dann sind es immer sehr aufgeregte Memes um ihn oder in denen er sehr aufgeregt ist. Ich vermute, die Aufregung, die jetzt auch rechtfertigt, dass wir hier über ihn sprechen, kommt unter anderem durch das Ausscheiden gegen Milan. Man hat im Hinspiel 0 zu 1 verloren und jetzt das Rückspiel mit 0 zu 0 geradezu spektakulär gestaltet. Jeweils hatte man einen Expected-Goes-Wert von unter 0, 5 oder genau 0, 5. Was ist los bei Tottenham? In der Liga sieht es ja eigentlich noch halbwegs gut aus mit Rang 4.
Aber gibt es das noch oder ist das einfach nur weniger sichtbar? In Deutschland ist es ja zum Beispiel so, dass es das halt noch gibt, aber halt in der Regel nicht mehr in den Innenstädten, sondern auf irgendeinem berühmten Acker und im Wald und Wiesengrund.
Das kann ich dir ganz ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen. Wenn, dann berichten die Medien nicht drüber. Vielleicht gibt es das noch. Aber da ist in den letzten Monaten und Jahren echt sehr, sehr ruhig geworden. Wie gesagt, das Schlimme ist nach wie vor der Rassismus hier. Der ist wirklich taff und das kriegst du auch nicht in die Köpfe der Leute rein. Das halte ich für eine ganz, ganz schwierige Geschichte.
Alexi, wie blickst du da drauf?
In Frankreich haben wir schon das Problem mit den Gegnerfans schon länger. Zum Beispiel beim Klassik. Una Big Masse, Paris Saint-Germain, sie haben seit 2013 keine gegnerischen Fans mehr erlaubt. Das ist fast bei jedem zweiten Spiel, dass keine Gegnerfans vor Ort sind. Bei denjenigen, die erlaubt sind, sind die Mannschaften, die so 200-300 Zuschauer mitbringen. Oder 2-3 Stück wie Monaco. Das Problem ist auch ein gesellschaftliches seit vielen Jahren in Frankreich. Das hat man auch als Gefühl, wie mit dem Rassismus in Spanien von Fabian erklärt oder beschrieben, dass wir kein Ende sehen, dass sowohl die Verantwortlichen von den Vereinen, als auch die politischen Verantwortlichen keine Maßnahmen ergreifen und sich dafür nicht wirklich interessieren. Das ist schon besorgnisierend, aber gleichzeitig schade, weil eine Masse der PSG-Mitfans von beiden Teams ist einfach etwas Wunderbares. Aber ich bin nicht wirklich überrascht, was gerade in Neapel passiert ist gegen die Eintracht. Man weiß noch in der Gruppenphase, was zwischen den Eintracht und den Olympique Marseille los war zwischen den Fans, sei es in Frankfurt oder in Marseille mit Auseinandersetzungen. Man weiß ja auch schon, dass es ein kleiner, aber doch nicht so kleiner Teil der Frankfurter Fans sind, die auch gewalttätig sind. Das ist bei Borussia Dortmund auch so. Es kommen jetzt immer mehr Geschichten über die Dortmunder Fans, die gewalttätig sind, die antisemitismische rufen. Sie haben es jetzt beim Revier-Durby rausgelassen. Es ist schon immer wieder ein Problem und man sieht einfach keine Lösung darin. Dass jetzt, meine Herren, vor wenigen Minuten Jan Infantino wieder gewählt wurde als Vifapräsidenten, ist auch dementsprechend nicht unbedingt eine gute Nachricht.
Ich finde, was die ganze Bewertung extrem schwierig macht, auch noch, Alexi hat es gerade gesagt, du hast es vorhin auch angedeutet, Max, zum einen sind die Szenen an sich ja sehr divers und welche grenzen sich ab und welche nicht. Und auf der anderen Seite ist ja auch sowohl, also vor allem gerade bei der Ultra-Bewegung, finde ich, dass so eine heterogene Subkultur auch, was die Unterschiede zwischen Vereinen angeht, also da wird das teilweise gelebt wie in den 80er, 90ern und bei anderen ist es völlig progressiv und es kommt fast gar nicht zu irgendwelchen Auseinandersetzungen.
Ja, und gleichzeitig eben der Fakt, auf den ja auch Alexis richtigerweise hingewiesen hat, es sind ja gesellschaftliche Entwicklungen, die sich im Fußball nur widerspiegeln und da wird der Fußball auch quasi nicht die Gesellschaft verändern können. Was mich ehrlicherweise frustriert ist, dass es anscheinend offenbar nur über Repression geht und letztlich über Kräfte messen. Das ist dann auch so eine nicht nur verbale Aufrüstung, die auf beiden Seiten passiert. Also auch normale Fans werden begrüßt von Bundespolizisten in Schlagmontur hier in Deutschland und in anderen Ländern. Da kriege ich es natürlich vor allem bei internationalen Spielen mit. Ich meine, ich habe es selbst in Rom erlebt. Da war ich mit der Eintracht im Stadion. Ich kenne sehr viele Berichte von den BVB-Fans damals, als sie in Sevilla waren. Also es gibt ja auch quasi schon so eine Erwartungshaltung. Ja, also wenn du da hingehst, dann musst du auch damit rechnen, das könnte richtig übel werden. Und daraus schließe ich jetzt, dass es auch in anderen Ländern eben vor allem darüber funktioniert, über Verbote und über ja, letztlich, wer von denen ist der Stärkere. Und dann kommt eben dann die Staatsmacht. Und das ist halt das, was mich so frustriert, weil das wird ja zu nichts führen. Also das wird nur dazu führen, dass es immer mal wieder eskaliert, dass es immer mal wieder der eine, die eine Seite der anderen ein Schnippchen schlägt. Also mal werden irgendwie die, die Polizei wird irgendwann, wird mal Fans einkesseln oder irgendwelche Kölner Fans zur Umkehr bewegen und wird das dann als Erfolg verkaufen können. Genauso werden aber halt auch Dortmund- und Essen-Fans, Schalke-Fans überfallen und da Leute kranken raus, Hausreif schlagen und sich dafür feiern. Und in seinem ganzen Destruktivismus macht mich das einfach müde. Und gleichzeitig sehe ich eben das einzige, was dagegen wirken könnte. Vielleicht wäre eben, dass man einfach investiert in die Jugend und in die Begleitung der Jugend. Und um eben zu verhindern, dass Menschen zu solchen Menschen werden, die eben dann über Gewalt sich einen Kick holen oder Probleme lösen wollen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann gucke ich eben, was passiert denn da auch im Fußball. Also es ist generell ein gesellschaftliches Ding, aber auch im Fußball. Ja, die Fan-Projekte machen reihenweise zu. Ihnen wird Geld entzogen. Die sagen schon seit ganz vielen Jahren, dass sie eigentlich zu wenig Geld haben. Und da tut sich nichts. Und das ist das, wo ich mich dann auch manchmal frage, warum der Journalismus, jetzt so ganz allgemein gesprochen, so selten bei diesen Themen rauskommt, wenn wir über Gewalt im Fußball sprechen. Sondern ich habe das Gefühl, es hört immer bei der Pyro-Fackel auf, dass ich da drüber aufgeregt würde. Und da kann man sich ja drüber aufregen. Es ist ja auch verboten. Aber warum kommen wir denn nicht zu dem, ja, was könnte man denn konstruktiv machen? Und ich habe das Gefühl, genau dasselbe passiert hier gerade bei der Napoli-Eintracht-Frankfurt-Sache auch, die ja auch nur ein Beispiel von leider vielen ist.
Ja, volle Zustimmung. Und die Fanprojekte finde ich auch ganz wichtiges Thema. In vielen Städten ist ja dann fast eher eigentlich der Freundeskreis, die Ultrakopierungen, die die Arbeit von Street-Workern oder Fanprojekten übernimmt und vielleicht auch Auffangbecken ist für ziellose Heranwachsende, die auf der Suche nach irgendetwas sind.
Das ist ja auch das. Also die Missachtung der Jugend, die Ausbeutung der Jugend und dann gleichzeitig, seid doch einfach mal wieder, habt doch einfach mal wieder Bock auf Arbeit, hatten wir doch früher auch und so. Also ja, es greifen so viele Themen ineinander. Wir müssen irgendwie die Kurve kriegen. Wir sind auch zeitlich schon ein bisschen drüber, wenn einer von euch irgendwie terminische Probleme bekommt, sagt es an. Wir machen jetzt, wenn wir eh schon bei den Scheißthemen sind, ich sage es einfach wie es ist, dann können wir jetzt über Korruption noch sprechen und dann danach wird uns aber Alexi mit einem Sexskandal richtig juicy dann noch hier rausschmeißen aus dieser Ligatur. Oh Gott, was habe ich da gerade gesagt? Ich moderiere einfach weiter, dann versende ich. Fabian, wir müssen noch über Bata sprechen.
Mir fällt gerade auf, es tut mir sehr leid, aber das werde ich mir auf jeden Fall, das ist gut angeteasert, ich werde es mir auf jeden Fall im Nachgang anhören. Leider kann ich jetzt nicht mitdiskutieren, aber ich sehe gerade, dass ich jetzt auch in einer Minute in einen Termin rein muss. Ich würde mich an der Stelle schon mal verabschieden.
Mach das, Mario. Dann bin ich froh, dass ich das schwere Thema noch rechtzeitig angesprochen habe. Mario, danke dir, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Der Ed Remedem auf Twitter. Danke dir, Mario. Viel Spaß in deinem anderen Termin.
Ob das Spaß für dich war?
So, und das wird hier so langsam wie bei der Sinfonie, wo einer nach dem anderen der Instrumentalisten rausgeht. Damals wollte damals der Kompositeur gegen seinen Lehnsherr oder seinen Mezzän dafür demonstrieren, dass man doch mal mehr Geld bekommen sollte. So wird jetzt diese Ligatour. Also Barca. Wir haben mitbekommen, dass man an den stellvertretenden Leiter der Spanischen Schiedsrichterkommission über mehrere Jahre hinweg 7 Millionen Euro gezahlt hat. Für Schiedsrichter nahe Leistungen, sagt Barca, also der hätte so Profile erstellt und Schulungen durchgeführt. So genau kann man aber nicht nachweisen. Was hat er denn eigentlich da so ganz konkret gemacht? Und der Verdacht liegt natürlich nahe, warum zahlt man so viel Geld, dass eben hier Korruption vorliegt bzw. eine Beeinflussung zumindest. Und da gab es jetzt neuere Entwicklungen, Fabian.
Ja, so viel Geld über so viele Jahre. Und das kam jetzt tatsächlich nicht nur den Spaniern spanisch vor, sondern auch dem Gericht und der spanischen Staatsanwaltschaft, die eine offizielle Anklage gegen den FC Barcelona eingeleitet hat. Und die wurde jetzt auch gestern stattgegeben. Das heißt, der Fall FC Barcelona beziehungsweise der Fall über die schiedsichtlichen Zahlungen oder die Zahlungen an diesem Schiedsichterausschuss, das wird jetzt vor Gericht ausgeführt, das ganze Thema. Da werden die verschiedenen Parteien vorgeladen und es kommt also hier zu einem richtig großen Gerichtsfall. Und da können wir wirklich sehr gespannt darauf sein, wie das ausgehen wird. Denn in Spanien, und das wissen wir glaube ich ja alle inzwischen, werden diese zwei großen Teams, Real Madrid und FC Barcelona, normalerweise behüte und beschützt wie der eigene Augapfel. Und es ist tatsächlich jetzt ein sehr interessanter Schritt, wie ich finde, dass es jetzt wirklich zur Gerichtsverhandlung kommt. Denn es könnte wirklich derbe Konsequenzen natürlich dann gegen den FC Barcelona geben. Ich denke da auch an die Geschichte, die bei Juve passiert ist in Italien und so weiter. Wir werden sehen, ob es soweit kommt. Aber Fakt ist natürlich, wenn man dem Schiedsrichterausschuss oder dem Vizepräsidenten des Spanischen Verbandes, des Schiedsrichterausschusses über 17 Jahre dann 7 Millionen Euro zusteckt, dann hat das einen faden Beigeschmack. Ich bin sehr gespannt, muss ich tatsächlich sagen, was dabei rauskommt und vor allen Dingen, ob dann wirklich auch eine dementsprechende Verurteilung stattfinden wird.
Und hat sich real dazu inzwischen eigentlich positioniert, weil das hatte ich in der letzten Ligatur angesprochen, der wir das Thema hatten, dass die auffallend ruhig waren und eigentlich sogar eher kritisch, wobei es halt auch ein bisschen schwierig voneinander zu trennen ist. Geht es hier um die Sache und geht es vielleicht um eine ganz, ganz mögliche, also es ist jetzt nur eine Vermutung oder eine These. Es könnte ja auch eine Mitbeteiligung gegeben haben, auch auf Seiten von Real. Also weil häufig war es bisher so, dass Dinge, die Barca gemacht hat, auch Real gemacht hat, ohne dass ich da irgendetwas wüsste, also mit aller Vorsicht gesprochen. Oder ob es einfach nur daran liegt, dass Real im Clinch liegt mit dem Spanischen Verband und das jetzt schon seit Jahren und eigentlich in die Super League will und so weiter und so fort. Oder auch männliche Egos aufeinander prallen.
Also Real Madrid hat zumindest jetzt dieser gemeinsamen Klage auch zugestimmt und ist da quasi mit anderen Vereinen in die Presche gesprungen, um dieses Gerichtsverfahren einzuleiten. Dementsprechend hat sich Real Madrid da jetzt auch klar positioniert. Du hast aber einen Punkt angesprochen und darüber, glaube ich, sollten wir uns schon auch im Klaren sein, auch Real Madrid – vielleicht nicht in der Art und Weise, wie es der FC Barcelona gemacht hat, aber auch Real Madrid – hat seine Finger überall drinstecken, ob es in der Politik sei, ob es bei den Schiedsrichtern sei. Auch die wissen sich die Gunst der Liga und der Spanischen Verbandes zu sichern. Also, ihr solltet trotzdem das Ganze mit Vorsicht genießen. Die wurden halt im Moment nicht irgendwie dabei erwischt, sage ich jetzt mal vorsichtig. Aber ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass auch dort Sachen passiert sind, die nicht alle völlig einwandfrei waren. Und dementsprechend tut Real Madrid sich ganz gut, sich da noch zurückzuhalten. Wie gesagt, sie haben jetzt damit zugestimmt, dass dieses Verfahren eingeleitet wird, was auch absolut normal ist. Wie gesagt, das haben alle anderen Vereine eher auch gemacht. Aber sonst halten sie sich noch relativ ruhig und da tun sie auch gut daran, denke ich mal.
Und jetzt ermittelt ja dann, glaube ich, der Richter ist es doch in Spanien, glaube ich, oder die Richterin, je nachdem, der dann die Entwicklung übernimmt. Also Staatsanwaltschaft, Reich, Klage ein und dann ist es ein Ermittlungsrichter. Genau, genau so ist es. Ja, also ich habe das Gefühl, wir werden da noch oft genug darüber sprechen, deswegen reicht vielleicht dieses kurze Update, denn ich weiß, alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die warten doch jetzt sowieso auf den Sex-Skandal bei Orangy, beziehungsweise was da überhaupt los ist. Alexis, bring uns auf den Aktorentstand. Wieviel müssen wir über Sportliches reden? Muss ich jetzt überhaupt die Tabelle der Ligue 1 aufmachen und gucken, wie es um Jean Angers gerade so steht? Oder hat es damit gar nichts zu tun?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Man kann schon kurz zusammenfassen, dass Angers vergleichbar ist von der sportlichen Entwicklung, aber auch vom Interesse in Frankreich zu diesem Verein, nämlich gar keine. Mir hätte es gehoffnet, weil Angers jetzt jahrelang der Ligue 1 war. Man hatte den französischen Christian Streich, der lange Stefan Moulin war, der über zehn Jahre dort Cheftrainer war. Seit er weg ist, geht es nur bergunter. In dieser Saison hat Angers jetzt nach 27 Spieltagen 10 Punkte geholt. Der Abstieg ist so gut wie besiegelt. Man sollte im Sommer ohne Trainer und Mannschaft stehen, aber vor allem ohne Präsidenten, denn er wird von Said Schabani, der Präsident von Skodange, angeklagt. Er ist übrigens als besten Vereinspräsidenten der Liga 2019 gewählt. Er ist jetzt von sieben Mitarbeiterinnen angeklagt worden wegen sexueller Belästigung, wenn nicht mehr, und jetzt muss er vor Gericht im Juni. Diese Geschichte kam schon vor eineinhalb Jahren raus und dann, zu dem gleichen Zeitpunkt, wurde ein Spieler auch von einer Frau angezeigt, weil er vor der Haustür, das war seine Nachbarin, hat seine Hose runtergemacht und sein bestes Stück gezeigt zur Nachbarin, die ihn dann sofort angezeigt hat. Das war der Anfang vom Ende für Angers, denn danach kamen immer mehr solche Geschichten. Letzte Geschichte, letzte Woche mit dem Interimstrainer Abdel Boazama, der einen Spieler von ihm schützen wollte, der auch angezeigt wurde wegen sexueller Belästigung oder Vergewaltigung sogar. Boazama hat den unglaublichen Satz rausgebracht, aber wir haben eh alle schon Frauen sexuell angefasst. Das war natürlich fatal für ihn, er musste dann seine Posten sofort abräumen und jetzt steht Angers ohne Trainer da und das sorgt natürlich für ein Skandal nach dem anderen und für ein sehr schlechtes Image eines Vereins, der bisher schuldlos war, wirklich ein absolutes Vorzeigeprofiferein war in den letzten Jahren bis seit 2021, 2022, wo dieser Verein einfach nur noch für negative Schlagzeilen sorgt und jetzt nicht nur extra sportliche Sachen, sondern jetzt auch natürlich sportliche Sachen und man hat das Gefühl, dass dieser Verein wirklich an die Wand gefahren wird und dann durch diese sexuellen Geschichten auch noch wirklich ganz große Probleme haben wird, um sich davon zu erholen, weil man hat schon das Gefühl, dass dieser Verein in der nächsten Saison auch um den Klassenerhalt in der 2. Liga kämpfen muss, weil wer wird dieser Verein übernehmen, mit welchen finanziellen Mitteln und wohl in einem Zeitpunkt, wo man ein nagelneues, renoviertes Stallion bauen lassen hat und wirklich sehr modern ist, mit einem auch großen Kern an Fans. Aber all diese Geschichten sorgen natürlich für Skandale, aber auch für Tristesse oder Inange.
Aber wenn das zum Beispiel sieben Mitarbeiterinnen sind, dann spricht das ja auch dafür, dass über einen längeren Zeitraum passiert ist, diese sexuellen Übergriffe. Und gleichzeitig ist es ja bei weitem nicht das Einzige, was wir jetzt im Männerfußball erlebt haben, wo man solche Beispiele hat. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob jetzt unsere Aufmerksamkeit darauf hingeschafft ist oder ob gerade mehr Dinge als sonst an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, eben was sexuelle Gewalt gegen Frauen angeht. Vielleicht liegt es auch daran, dass es inzwischen ein anderes Bewusstsein dafür gibt, Dinge zur Anzeige zu bringen. Glaubst du, Ingenie ist wirklich ein Einzelfall? Das ist natürlich jetzt hochspekulativ und so weiter. Aber man muss jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel hypothetisch sich dazudenken, um halt Muster zu erkennen im Fußball. Dass wir immer wieder Spieler haben, die wegen Dingen beschuldigt und angeklagt werden, dass wir immer wieder Vereine und männliche Funktionäre haben, die diese Spieler dann schützen, die auch sich selbst schützen. Wie blickst du da drauf? Einzelfall oder vielleicht Symptom eines größeren Musters?
Ich befürchte, dass es kein Einzelfall ist, weil warum soll das nur in Angers passieren? Eigentlich hätte ein Verein, den man nie hätte zutrauen können, dass solche Geschichten auf einmal rauskommen. Ich denke schon, dass es bei anderen Vereinen der Fall ist, nur da werden die Hauptschulen wahrscheinlich noch geschützt. Die Frage ist, wie lang. Irgendwann kommt immer alles raus. Ich wäre sehr verwundert, wenn da nicht mehr mehr rauskommt in den nächsten Jahren. Aber auch bei anderen Vereinen, auch mal in Deutschland oder in England, wo auch alles unter dem Teppich versteckt wird. Es kann nicht sein, dass bei Vereinen, wo so viel los ist, so viele Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiterinnen, dass es nur ein Einzelfall bleiben kann. Das halte ich für so gut wie ausgeschlossen.
Was ja schon ein unglaublich deprimierender Befund ist eigentlich und dennoch muss man dir da natürlich zustimmen. Löst es denn auch eine größere Debatte aus in Frankreich? Das habe ich natürlich jetzt nicht so im Blick, wie die Medien über sowas berichten.
Nicht unbedingt, weil Angers ist nur Angers. Wie gesagt, wenn jetzt in Hoffenheim auch solche Geschichten passieren würden, wäre natürlich die Titelseite zwei, drei Tage. Aber Hoffenheim ist nicht Dortmund, nicht Frankfurt und noch auch nicht Bayern München. Deswegen kann man froh sein, auch wenn es sich komisch anhört, dass es nur Angers ist, aber stell dir vor, es wäre bei Marseille oder Olympique Lyonnais oder natürlich auch Katar St. Germain der Fall, was es dann für Schlagzeilen bringen würde. Dann wäre das natürlich auch ein großes Thema in den französischen Tagesthemen. Aber es ist nur Angers und hoffentlich bleibt es so, dass nicht andere Vereine kommen, dass alles normal läuft. Aber ich befürchte schon, dass da immer mehr rauskommt durch unsere heutige Welt, dass Angers nicht ein Einzelfall bleiben wird.
Ohje, was für ein deprimierendes Thema und ich möchte mich ausdrücklich dafür entschuldigen, dass ich das so launisch mit Sexskandal anmoderiert habe. Ich hatte gehofft, dass es um irgendwas mit Konsent geht und dass da einfach viele Leute Spaß miteinander hatten, aber das war dann natürlich völlig unpassend. Da habe ich einfach total die falsche Abzweigung genommen, weil ich mich nicht vorher informiert habe, was in Angers so los ist. Also dafür entschuldigung, das war total unpassend und ja, aber gut, das ist mir jetzt so passiert. Es tut mir sehr leid. Muss ich das nächste Mal ein bisschen besser arbeiten. Ihr zwei, ich danke euch, dass ihr euch quasi, dass ihr in die Verlängerung gegangen seid mit dieser Ligatur, die nicht immer einfache Themen hatte, aber so ist das eben halt auch im Fußball. Wir sind quasi das Abbild des Abbilds. Der Fußball ist ein Abbild der Gesellschaft und wir müssen dann dieses Abspiel dann reportieren. Umso mehr danke ich euch beiden, dass ihr hier war. Zum einen Fabian Pakulat, der Ed-Rosen-Gartler, auf Twitter. Danke dir, Fabian, dass du mal wieder hier mit dabei warst und da bin ich sehr gespannt, was du dann über das neue katarische Projekt Malaga in Zukunft so berichten wirst, hier im Rasenfunk. Danke dir. Und ganz herzlichen Dank an Alexis Menuge. Danke, dass du auch diese Themen neben dem Platz mitbringst, denn sie sind wichtig. Danke dir, Alexis, dass du wieder im Rasenfunk warst.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja, das nächste Mal. Das wird dann in zwei Wochen stattfinden. So ist zumindest der aktuelle Plan. Aber das ist unser aktueller Rhythmus. Nächste Woche werdet ihr im Kurzpass hoffentlich zwei Folgen hören. Einmal zum letzten Frauen-Bundesliga-Spieltag. Da möchte ich euch schon mal empfehlen. Die letzte Folge, da habe ich Svenja Hut vom VfL Wolfsburg interviewt und wir haben natürlich auch die Spiele analysiert. Im nächsten Frauen-Kurzpass wird dann Nina Lürsen von Werder Bremen interviewt werden. Wenn die euch noch nicht sagt, dann hört euch dieses Interview an. Danach wisst ihr, warum ihr ein Auge auf sie haben sollte. Ganz interessante Sportlerin, die auch eine Meinung hat, dass es sehr wohltuend. Also das wird dann am nächsten Montag erscheinen und am nächsten Donnerstag. So denn die Gästeplanung es zulässt, werden wir hoffentlich über die 2. Männer-Bundesliga Deutschland sprechen. Das ist das, was hier im Kurzpass passiert und in der Schlusskonferenz bekommt ihr natürlich am Wochenende wieder einen Rückblick auf den Männerspieltag der 1. Liga. Also es geht einfach genauso weiter wie die letzten Wochen. In diesem Sinne bleibt gesund, unterstützt den Rasenfunk bitte finanziell rasenfunk.de support das Club, denn nur diese Unterstützung macht den Rasenfunk möglich und nur das ermöglicht uns auch Unabhängigkeit. Und vielleicht haben wir heute auch so ein paar Themen gehabt, wo man gehört hat, es ist nicht so schlecht unabhängig zu sein. Macht's gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk.